una corte saudita con moto las penas de
muerte en contra de cinco de los
presuntos asesinos de jamal ja sóc y en
estambul a cambio recibirán condenas de
20 años de cárcel otro fue sentenciado a
10 años de prisión y dos sospechosos más
a siete años los nombres de los
indicados jamás fueron revelados y la
prensa estatal comunicó el cierre del
caso de yamaha shops y ni lee la
sentencia suman en conjunto 124 años de
prisión para los culpables con la
decisión final el caso criminal tanto
público como privado ha cerrado
entre tanto la familia del periodista
desaparecido y su expareja criticaron la
resolución está sentencia entregada hoy
por arabia saudita es una total burla a
la justicia las autoridades sauditas
están cerrando el caso sin que el mundo
sepa la verdad sobre quién es el
responsable por el asesinato de jamal
que lo planeó que él ordenó dónde está
su cuerpo estas son las preguntas más
básicas e importantes que permanecen sin
respuesta alguna la comunidad
internacional no aceptará esta farsa
estoy más determinada que nunca en
luchar para lograr justicia para llamar
a la condena se unió la alta comisionada
de la onu para las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales aniés calama es quien
estudió el caso de cerca los cinco
asesinos fueron condenados a 20 años de
prisión pero los altos responsables que
organizaron y planearon el asesinato de
jamal chabti están libres en cuanto a la
responsabilidad del príncipe heredero
mohamed bin salman ésta no fue abordada
ja sóc y desapareció el 2 de octubre de
2018 mientras visitaba el consulado de
arabia saudita en estambul para
solicitar documentos para poder contraer
matrimonio en turquía con hat y change
is las autoridades turcas revelaron que
jamal fue descuartizado en la sede
diplomática
la cia concluyó que el asesinato fue
directamente ordenado por el príncipe
mohamed bin salman quien nunca rindió
cuentas ante la justicia